Unless One Piece pulls a major final twist
that ends the story in absolute tragedy, we
can pretty much say for certain that Luffy
will become pirate king, defeat the big baddies
and change the world.
But…then what?
What is going to happen to all of the straw
hats and, most importantly, what will the
one piece world look like 10 years after the
world is saved?
Luckily we know exactly what many of our favorite
characters would probably be up to based on
their dreams and foreshadowing in the story.
Like Sanji who will have found the All Blue,
and Robin who will finally learn the true
history of the world.
And then there’s Luffy who at this point
will have actually already achieved his dream,
and if we are being honest my personal bet
is that Luffy actually dies at the end of
the story because he is kinda like this Jesus
figure who sacrifices himself to save everyone.
But let’s stay positive and assume that
he survives, like maybe Chopper somehow heals
all the lifespan he has lost, and now he is
the freest man in the world.
Which takes us ten years into the future,
where Luffy is about to set out on his next
major adventure.
So he steps out of his family’s home on
New Dawn Island.
And what is this new, unheard of island?
Well, it’s a new island formed after the
collapse of the Red Line where all the races
of the world have basically come to live together.
And this island is insane!
The main part is jam packed with houses
and a massive party area in the center.
Because of course, it’s Luffy’s island
and what else would he rather do but party
with all of his friends.
Speaking of those friends, here’s a shocker
for you.
Luffy is married AND has a four year old daughter
named Lily.
But we’ll save the surprise of who actually
tied this rubber man down for a bit later.
Because for now Luffy is on a mission.
He wants to throw a massive party for his
kid’s fifth birthday, so that of course
means inviting his friends.
ALL OF HIS FRIENDS.
But of course there is ONE.
BIG.
PROBLEM.
Only SOME of the former straw hat pirates
actually live on the island.
Which ones?
Well, we’ll see in just a moment as Luffy
leaves home with just his straw hat and a
bag full of invitations, but before setting
out, he has a few invitations to deliver around
the island.
And on his way, we can see what an incredibly
diverse place New Dawn Island has become.
That’s because many of the people that Luffy
befriended on his journey to become pirate
king now live here on the island.
There are fishmen, minks, mermaids, giants,
tontattas, Skypieans, all going about their
business within the various districts of the
town which are filled with shops and restaurants
from all across the one piece world.
There is even an amusement park and a giant
music area in the very center of the island.
Which is EXACTLY what you would expect Luffy’s
island would look like.
So now let’s explore the rest of the island.
So Luffy hops over to the first of these mini
islands.
And these are actually super cool because
they house some of his closest friends.
This one right here closest to Luffy’s house
is actually Sanji, and his wife Pudding’s,
world-famous, five-star restaurant.
This restaurant is basically the completion
of Sanji’s dream, since New Dawn Island
is located right in the middle of the famous
All Blue - which is where all four seas joined
together.
And while we don’t know for sure that this
will happen in the main story, I personally
think it is pretty likely that the Red Line
will be destroyed, at least the part where
Reverse Mountain is - because I mean come
on, it is basically X marks the spot.
And if this part is destroyed that will leave
space for New Dawn Island to form out of the
rubble.
So Luffy swings straight through the front
door, pops his first invitation into Sanji’s
chef hat, and then grabs ALL OF THE FOOD that
Sanji and his chefs have SPENT HOURS preparing
and stuffs it into a giant sack for his long
trip around the world.
At first Sanji is furious and he runs after
Luffy but after he stops to read the invitation
he just smiles.
That’s one straw hat down.
Many more to go.
Luffy’s next stop is this little island,
which is home to two world famous buildings.
The first is a university founded by the greatest
archeologist in the world, Nico Robin.
She created this place with her good buddy
Saul so that anyone who wanted to study archeology
and the ancient past could gather here to
learn.
But as Luffy barges into Robin’s office
he finds that she is apparently out on some
grand expedition.
So add her to the list of ones to find out
in the world.
So then he hops over to the hospital on the
other half of the island where Dr. Chopper
and Dr. Law can basically cure any disease.
They even have a super cool bird ambulance
system which can bring in patients from all
over the world.
But that’s now Chopper and Law both invited.
Check.
Next up is this middle island, which is actually
where many of the patients of the hospital
come from.
Why is that?
Well, it’s because this island houses Jinbe’s
fishman karate school, where he trains anyone
who wants to learn how to fight alongside
this former fishman revolutionary.
So that’s Jinbe invited, and on the same
island is the massive Never Lost dojo, where
anyone can come learn the way of the sword.
And this place is super cool because Zoro
actually hosts monthly tournaments for anyone
wanting to challenge his title as the world’s
strongest swordsman.
Which if we’re being honest it is probably
good that people come to him because we all
know he’d get lost trying to find strong
opponents.
But for some reason he is also off of the
island.
I wonder what he is doing out in the world…
After leaving the dojo, Luffy flies over to
the brightest of the little islands, which
is funnily enough called Golden island - hmm,
wonder who named it that.
Guess we’ll find out soon enough.
On this island is a massive casino run by
the former Warlord Crocodile, and when Luffy
goes inside he finds his old mentor Rayleigh
hanging out with his gambling buddy, Kizaru.
Apparently after the light fruit user left
the marines, these two quickly became friends.
Plus Kizaru’s light speed is super helpful
whenever Rayleigh needs to escape whenever
his longtime lover demands he actually brings
home some money.
And right next to the Casino is the local
branch of the Tangerine Bank.
And who is the head of this bank?
Well, none other than the grown up O-tama
who trained under a certain cat burglar we
know and love.
But why is she running a bank?
Keep watching to find out later on.
Now there’s one more stop before Luffy leaves,
and that is the Research Lab on this final
island right here.
And this is where all the fun starts because
as soon as Luffy arrives a massive explosion
shakes the island.
Out of the smoke comes a giant version of
his Grandpa Garp.
Luffy is actually super excited to see a mega-sized
Garp, but that instantly changes when his
grandpa’s massive fist comes rushing straight
towards him.
But just as the fist is about to crush Luffy,
it explodes into flashing lights and sparks.
Then out of the smoke comes the genius scientist
Dr. Vegapunk, who can’t stop from laughing
at his hologram prank.
You see, Vegapunk set up shop here on New
Dawn Island, and even though he doesn’t
get all the funding from the government that
he used to he can still make some pretty cool
stuff to help out the world.
Luffy will definitely spend some time playing
around with some of Vegapunk’s fun new technology,
which you can actually see in use all over
the town, and then Luffy leaves him with some
instructions for the party.
And with that, Luffy jumps over to the other
side of the main island.
He stops by Usopp’s house, but he is also
curiously missing.
Then he flies past the tiny new government
building that no one cares about and skips
right to the new Franky Family inc warehouse,
which is where Franky comes up with all of
his crazy inventions.
And the most important of those is the new
and improved Sea Train, which is currently
leaving the station at warp speed.
Luffy somehow manages to stretch and grab
on, and his new adventure to invite all of
his friends is now fully underway.
And as he leaves, a giant hologram of his
face appears in the sky above the island,
announcing his daughter’s birthday party
to everyone on the island.
A massive cheer goes up, and Luffy smiles.
Seems like Vegapunk understood his message
just fine.
However, despite how awesome Luffy’s home
island is, he is really excited to head out
to sea after so much time on land.
Plus there’s six other former crewmates
and A TON of other important friends to find
out in the world.
Which brings us to a super important part
of this scenario…
Now that we are setting out into the world,
we need to know what exactly happened to the
world after Luffy became pirate king?
Well, while we don't know for certain, there
are a few things that will most likely happen
at the end of the story.
Luffy will find the One Piece and become pirate
king.
He will take down the corrupt world nobles
and bring the dawn to the world, which basically
means set the world free.
These few things are basically guaranteed
to happen - unless Oda-sensei pulls some crazy
twist that no one is expecting.
And I’m sure it will be super easy to find
a perfect political system to rule an entire
planet, but for now let’s assume that there
is a new government that works way better
than the last one.
There are still pirates - even bad pirates
- but the good pirates and marines do a good
job of keeping them from doing too much damage.
And with Luffy having such a diverse crew,
there is much less discrimination against
other races in the world.
Which is actually part of Franky’s purpose
for creating the new Sea Train, which will
eventually connect the entire world.
And this is super important for Luffy’s
current journey because as we all know Luffy
could never get anywhere sailing on his own..
The first stop after New Dawn Island is Elbaf,
where Luffy brings some invitations for the
new leaders of the giants.
These days not only giants live here because
after making friends with Usopp they are open
to anyone who wants to become a brave warrior.
Luffy was also hoping to find Shanks and Usopp
here, but it seems that the giants haven’t
seen Shanks in a while and Usopp is out adventuring
with his dad.
Finally, it took ten years for the dead-beat
dad pirates to actually spend time with their
kids.
So back on the train, Luffy's next stop is
Wano.
But suddenly a massive explosion rocks the
train.
The train is fine, because I mean Franky made
it and have you seen the kind of stuff he
makes?
But Luffy looks out the window and he sees
this massive ship speeding toward the train.
And while other passengers freak out, Luffy
is thrilled to see Buggy, who is the new ruler
of Pirate Island.
However, Buggy seems determined to take out
the train and Luffy comes out to stop him.
However, as Luffy is about to charge up a
Gomu Gomu no attack, he hears an incredibly
familiar voice shouting from on top of the
train.
He turns around and is ABSOLUTELY shocked
to find his four year old daughter, Lily,
shouting insults at the Buggy pirates across
the waves.
Before he can stop her, she jumps up, catches
a cannon ball and throws it back at the oncoming
ship.
Which sounds ridiculous, but this is Luffy’s
kid after all.
Then out of nowhere, a giant ship from Elbaf
appears, and cuts off Buggy’s ship, allowing
the train to continue on without Luffy having
to even fight.
Because that is actually part of the allied
countries' jobs to protect the sea train route.
But now that his kid is on board, all he can
do is laugh and take her along for the ride.
Though, I’d bet Luffy’s wife is not going
to be happy AT ALL when they return.
Anyways, onto the land of the samurai.
Here Momo is still the Shogun and the borders
have finally been opened to the rest of the
world.
And here is where we find our favorite green-haired
swordsman, because apparently his wife, who
is Momo’s sister Hiyori, dragged him back
to her home to see her family.
But when Luffy tells him about the party,
he cannot resist the invitation and even decides
to join the journey to find the other crewmates,
so cross another one off the list.
But that’s not all to see in Wano because
Luffy’s old marine rivals, Smoker and Tashigi,
now run an orphanage and a sword museum, where
Tashigi shows off all of the famous blades
that they have collected from bad pirates
over the years.
Because where else would you have a sword
museum except the place that literally makes
the best blades in the world.
The next stop is Whole Cake Island.
These islands used to be the home of the Emperor
Big Mom, but now our donut loving mochi man,
Katakuri, has created a ton of world famous
bakeries on the many islands of Totto Land.
And that’s because originally these islands
were all themed around food like chocolate
and fluffy cakes, so it is only natural that
Katakuri would want to take all these resources
to make the absolute best sweets in the entire
world.
Of course he really just wants to eat them
all himself, but he would definitely share
when Luffy and the gang come to drop off an
invitation.
So after losing to Lily in a sweet’s eating
contest, they all take the train to Dressrosa.
And I’m actually starting to wonder if we
will find any of the other straw hats here.
Once they land, they see that the island has
been rebuilt and the tribe of dwarves who
helped save the kingdom from the evil warlord
Doflamingo ten years ago are now a full part
of the kingdom.
Luffy invites all of his friends to the party,
and then gives special instructions to Leo,
the leader of the Tontattas, to pass out invitations
to the rest of the Straw Hat Grand Fleet.
But, as we will see at the end of this video,
this actually creates a huge problem for Luffy,
as we’ll discuss later on.
By this time about a week has passed, and
we’ve reached the exact opposite side of
the world.
Which may seem super fast to travel as far
as they have, but remember this Sea Train
was made by Franky, so of course it is Suuuppper
fast.
And between adventuring on islands and practicing
swords with her uncle, Lily is having the
time of her life, but we’ve only found Zoro
so far.
Where is everyone else?
And how about Luffy’s brother?
And his dad?
What are they all doing?
But in this super important location, which
used to be where Mary Geoise was located is
this new island right here is also the headquarters
of the newly established government of the
world.
After the fall of the previous government,
the world basically just took out the Celestial
Dragons and other evil rulers and made some
new system of government with elected officials
from allied kingdoms and even some pirate
crews.
And while the system is not perfect - let’s
be honest no government is - Luffy’s brother
Sabo now spends his days basically watching
over it to make sure any corruption is stamped
out.
At least that is what he is supposed to be
doing when he’s not chowing down on delivery
orders of Sanji’s famous ramen.
However, Sabo agrees to take time off, and
Luffy also drops off an invitation for the
new marine admiral Koby as well.
However, as great as it is to see his brother,
Luffy doesn’t care to stick around the government
for long, so they quickly hop back on the
train and continue their adventure.
Which takes them back to the location of the
original Sea Train on Water 7, where surely
we have to meet another straw hat.
Now this island is completely different from
when we visited in the original story.
And that’s because it isn’t even an island
anymore.
Remember that Water 7 was sinking because
of these giant waves.
But that is no longer an issue because together
Franky and the mayor of Water 7 Iceberg finally
managed to transform the entire city into
a giant floating ship.
Franky has of course also decked out his former
home with some fun new technology, but the
most incredible invention of all is a fleet
of massive balloons which allow people to
safely reach Skypiea.
Which is exactly where the gang heads next
and it is up in the clouds that they FINALLY
meet up with some old friends.
That’s because Usopp and Yasopp are having
a friendly sniping competition trying to snipe
the golden bell from miles away, but right
next to them is one of the few honorary Straw
Hats, Yamato.
That’s right, Yamato has finally gotten
out to explore the world, just like she promised
at the end of the Wano arc.
And boy is she happy to see Luffy.
In fact, after their competition they all
drop off some invitations with their Skypiean
friends and then Usopp and Yamato – yes
for real this time – both join the group
and head back down to the surface.
We’ve finally got some other straw hats
on board.
I am seriously hoping the others didn’t
die or something.
However, there is one major problem coming
up ahead.
And that’s because the train doesn’t continue
forever.
You see when the train reaches the end of
the tracks, the group finally finds Franky
who is working with his new crew of cyborg
construction workers to complete the Sea Train
tracks.
But no train means no more free rides, but
this isn’t an issue for long because Franky
has the Thousand Sunny.
So when Luffy asks, Franky of course agrees
to come with them on their trip, so the gang,
along with our Super Cyborg, continue onward.
Which brings us to Alabasta, where its basically
raining down straw hats.
Alabsata has actually become a world famous
hot spring destination.
Thanks a bunch, Gedatsu.
Vivi is currently ruling the kingdom after
her dad passed away, but politics are not
currently on her mind at all because she is
rocking out at a concert for the worldwide
musical phenomenon, Soul King Brook.
That’s right, our straw hat skeleton has
gone back to being a rockstar and he travels
the world with his whale friend, Laboon.
He’s not the only former straw hat here
though, because Robin is also enjoying the
concert while taking a break from studying
in the Royal Alabasta Library.
So after enjoying the concert, Vivi, Brook,
and Robin all join with the crew, and together
- with Laboon tailing behind - they set out
for what used to be East Blue.
And here they enter the domain of the mega-rich
bank CEO, Nami.
Which might surprise you, but after finishing
her map of the entire world, Nami sold her
completed navigational charts and made a massive
fortune.
She then took that money, started a world
wide banking group, Tangerine Banks and has
basically become the richest person in the
entire world.
I guess she doesn’t need to charge her friends
300% interest anymore.
She even has bought everyone in her hometown
a massive mansion to pay back all of the trouble
she caused as a kid.
But when her friends arrive, Luffy’s former
Navigator drops everything to give Lily a
giant hug, and then she immediately takes
over sailing the ship with the crew.
Which is all of the crew, but there are still
some super important friends to find.
And the next stop is Luffy’s hometown, the
former Goa Kingdom.
However, upon arrival they immediately run
into trouble.
Cannon balls start splashing down everywhere
around the ship.
And that’s because Luffy’s Grandpa Garp
is chucking the missiles at the ship from
the shore, while Luffy’s dad Dragon lounges
nearby eating his favorite greasy sandwiches.
But after they land and Lily proceeds to beat
up her great-grandpa, Luffy invites the two
to the party back on New Dawn Island.
Shanks also comes down to meet the gang at
the beach, and he is joined by the barkeeper
Makino and their own boy who is now around
ten years old.
And of course, it is entirely possible that
not all of these three super powerful fighters
are still alive, but for now we don’t know
so I’m just going to add them in anyways.
Now, with all the invitations delivered it
is time to head back to New Dawn Island, where
with all of his friends reunited he throws
one of the greatest parties the world has
ever seen to celebrate Lily’s birthday.
Which is of course the BEST case scenario
for what could happen after One Piece, but
what if things actually went horribly wrong
for Luffy and his friends.
And instead of becoming pirate king, Luffy
was instead captured and sentenced to be executed
by the world government.
Which is absolutely insane to think about
all of the people who would come to rescue
him that I just had to make an entire video
to see if Luffy would actually survive.
And you can watch that right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.